top gun Maverick reveals that Maverick
and Iceman's friendship endured in the
decades since the events of Top Gun
which is why ice now an admiral calls on
his old buddy and colleague to return to
the Top Gun program to prepare its top
10 fighter pilots for a crucial Mission
but while a reunion of Cruz and Kilmer
and top gun Maverick seem like a
no-brainer and an easy task for Cruz and
his collaborators getting Kilmer to
reprise Iceman was tricky due to the
actor's real-life Health battles in
recent years in 2017 Val Kilmer revealed
that he was diagnosed with throat cancer
which largely robbed him of his ability
to speak despite Kilmer's health issues
the UK's Express online reported that
Crews did not want to make top gun
Maverick without Kilmer's participation
according to the publication Kilmer's
son jack who sounds remarkably like his
father as he narrates Val lent his voice
to top gun Maverick and the production
used new technology to combine their
performances Kilmer was so impressed by
what sinantic produced that he issued a
statement saying semantic masterfully
restored my voice in a way I've never
imagined possible